Freunde herzlich willkommen zu einer
weiteren Folge ein Tag persönlicher Koch
und mein heutiger Gast steht hier an
meiner Seite mit einem gewagten Outfit
hier für Kölner Verhältnisse Marvin ist
da und du hast dir was Leckeres zum
Frühstück gewünscht men einer meiner
Leibspeisen das Hof okay das hoffe ich
ich hoffe dass dein ich hoffe dass ich
es gut hinbekomme ich habe alles schon
vorbereitet du kennst den Spaß mach dir
ganz bequem mach dir gemütlich ich
Zauber das ganze und dann rufe ich dich
wenn es das Essen ich wusste nicht dass
es so aufwendig ist tut mir schon fast
leid ach kein Problem ich bin gespannt
Marin hat sich für Klassiker entschieden
der türkischen frühstücksküche manem und
schon 50 Cent gesagt man man wish death
upon me wir haben alles hier was wir
brauchen in der klassischen Ausführung
einmal eine grüne Spitzpaprika peterilie
darf nicht fehlen paar Snacks so an der
Seite also Gurken Oliven bisschen feter
noch mal das wird einfach köstlich und
es ist verdammt einfach deshalb bin ich
dankbar für dieses Gericht was Marvin
sich da ausgesucht hat wir starten mit
ordentlich Olivenöl in der Pfanne und
geben zu allererst einmal unsere
Spitzpaprika rein die sieht übrigens so
aus ein bisschen vorgeschnibbelt die
Paprika ist schön glasig und jetzt geben
wir auch schon unsere Zwiebel hinzu und
auch die dünsten wir ein bisschen an
jetzt hier eine Tomate die werde ich
einfach mal Würfeln das machen wir für
die Textur weil wir arbeiten eigentlich
mit poulper also tomatenfuchtfleisch das
Ding ist wir wollen den Geschmack von
reifentomaten und die Textur von
frischen Tomaten deshalb nehmen wir
beides wow das verbindet sich jetzt
schon wunderschön Zack und wir geben die
poper dazu dadurch wird es auch nicht so
wässrig dass wir jetzt die polper
verwenden müssen wir es nicht ewig
einkochen aber wir lassen es jetzt
erstmal ein bisschen köchn ich habe Nour
ein bisschen Tomate Gurke und feterkäse
geschnibbelt und das rie ich jetzt
einfach noch so ein bisschen auf so
Teller an den wir dazu legen und auch
klassisch dass man so zu einem
türkischen Frühstück noch so ein
bisschen Gemüse dazu reicht jetzt würzen
wir unser meneman mit ein bisschen Chili
dafür haben wir diese klassische
getrocknete türkische Chili so noch eine
Prise Salz dran dann rühren wir noch
einmal durch und wir sehen dass jetzt
weitestgehend die Feuchtigkeit schon
rausgekocht ist was genau richtig ist
ein absoluter Traum und jetzt kümmern
wir uns um die Eier wir haben auf jeden
Fall Hunger wir sind viele und wir essen
Eier in die Schüssel geben so eine
schöne Prise Salz ans Ei dann können wir
auch schon
verquüen das sind zwei richtig schöne
Fladenbrote die ich beim türkischen
Bäcker geholt habe so ab in Ofen werend
das jetzt noch mal aufwärmt gebe ich
mein Ei oben auf die meneman Mischung
drauf jetzt kommt der Trick nicht zu
viel mixen also quasi einmal ordentlich
durchrühren jetzt werde ich zum toppen
noch ein bisschen petasilie schnibbeln
gehört einfach dazu in der türkischen
Küche dann haben wir jetzt auch hier
unser maneman was für mich die perfekte
Konsistenz hat daran geh jetzt zunächst
mit ein bisschen feterkäse das ganze
noch mal ein bisschen Würz kemigkeit
reingibt und ein wenig Petersilie zum
Abschluss das sieht do einfach toll aus
oder und fertig ist unsere meneman
Pfanne so mein lieber das Frühstück ist
gerichtet einmal menem dazu habe ich ein
schönes fladenbotwen gemacht bisschen
was geschnibbelt was gesundes du bist ja
bisschen gesundheitsbewusst habe ich das
Gefühl ja jetzt seit ein paar Wochen ja
ich merke dass das Alter mich langsam
einholt mit 27 ist es so wie du dir ja
vorstellst schon mal visuell es sieht
ein aus als wäre ich in kölnkalk
wirklich sehr gut ja dann bedien dich
einfach nehm dir was no schön warm aus
dem Ofen bitte sehr geil vielen Dank
Zack und dann können wir einfach mal
reinppen so wie hast eben genan
räuberteller ein räuberteller kannst was
runternehmen safe machen das hier so du
probierst lässt dir noch nicht allzu
viel anmerken und dann kannst du dir ein
paar Gedanken machen dann geht aber auch
die Kamera aus damit Du in Ruhe genießen
kannst und dann dein Essen kosten kannst
dann probier mal und lass dir nicht
allzu viel anmerken guten Pfanne ist
leer das ist schon mal ein gutes Zeichen
Marvin ich hoffe dir hat geschmeckt aber
sag einfach mal selbst es war wirklich
atemauend genau die richtige Menge Ei
drin es hat wirklich fantastisch
geschmeckt dass du hier an diese kleinen
hppchen noch gedacht hast ein warmes
Brot dazu also ich habe mich wirklich
ich fühle mich gerade wie in ISM fehlt
nur noch die Sonne sehr schön ja die
Sonne müssen wir glaub ich noch ein
bisschen drauf warten hier in California
ne ich freue mich dass dir geschmeckt
hat wenn du das ganze jetzt in eine
Bewertung fassen müsstest von 0 bis 10
was was steht da drauf man kann echt
nichts besser ist jetzt kein Süßholz
raspeln aber ich würde schon eine 10 von
ze geben hör mal so können wir gut in
den Tag starten ze von ze super so
machen weiter perfekt einfach genauso
nein richtig geil wir kümmern uns jetzt
ums Mittagessen es ist Zeit fürs
Mittagessen Marvin guck mal was ich hier
feines habe ich dachte wir machen Burger
und jetzt komm es hier mit sowas
hochwertigem an im Herzstück von unserem
Burger steht ein US Prime entrecode es
ist fast ein bisschen schade das zu
Wolfen eine richtig tolle marmorerung
aber das wird diesen Burger den du dir
gewünscht hast aufs nächste Level heben
weil du hast gesagt du willst einen Low
Carb Burger das ist eine Herausforderung
das heißt wir können nicht mit super
viel Ketchup in Soße arbeiten wir müssen
alles relativ Zucker und Kohlenhydrat
frei halten warum lowup weil ich jetzt
nach mehreren Jahren auch mal merke ich
sollte mal ein bisschen versuchen fitter
zu werden also du siehst Fett aus auf
jeden Fall ja das ist immer das ist
immer die Größe L die mich so aussehen
lässt aber ab hier gib nim so eine Kegel
V ja ja das das passiert im besten ich
würde sagen ich mache mich mal wieder an
die Arbeit ich hoffe du hast schon
wieder Hunger weil das was wir hier
jetzt bekommen ist glaube ich richtig
lecker darf ich zusehen klar ich will
nämlich auch was lernen ich kann
überhaupt nichts in der Kü aler Trick
ich schon paar mal gezeigt auf meinem
Channel einfach wenn du den perfekten
Bacon willst legst du den einfach auf de
Backblech schiebst bei 200° in Ofen und
wartest bis er fertig ist guten Bacon
macht man im Ofen so ab in den Ofen 200°
sind vorgeheizt einfach reinleiden und
ein bisschen Geduld die burgerbands lege
ich dann später dazu dass wir die noch
mal frisch aufbacken jetzt würde ich
sagen Wolfen wir erstmal unser ontrikot
deshalb hauen wir das jetzt hier einmal
rein daraus formen wir dann gleich
unsere Patties raten die schön an hier
sieht man richtig schön dass da auch
viel Fett dabei ist und das ist einfach
geschmackp mit diesem schönen gereiften
Fleisch einfach lecker hier ist unser
Premium Hackfleisch jetzt das brauchen
wir für den Burger aber ich würde sagen
ein guter Burger braucht noch mehr als
ein gutes Petty wir machen noch ein paar
schöne karamellisierte Zwiebeln dazu ein
bisschen Butter hier in den Topf rein zu
heiß schon die Panne wir warten kurz bis
die Pfanne nicht ich warte kurz das
dauert nicht lange ja dann z so Butter
rein und direkt dazu unsere Zwiebeln der
perfekte Bacon ist ready lassen wir
jetzt einfach schön abkühlen und du
musst es ja gar nichts machen einfach
nur reinstellen sich einfach nur ein
reinstellen das kann ich
gut hier haben wir jetzt den Bacon man
sieht schön der hält die Form ich leg
den jetzt noch ein bisschen auf zer
damit der weniger fertig ist und auch
knusprig bleibt schau mal die Zwiebeln
werden gerade sehr schnell sehr braun
sieht absolut super aus wir machen ein
bisschen die expressvion deshalb ist in
Ordnung wenn die so so halb Frittieren
habe ich auch wieder genug Kommentare
fürs Video heute denn ich tue westerser
Soße rein das ist die Soße von der
keiner den Namen aussprechen kann wie
würdest du es sagen
W Rest schier ja die die ist es sind
aufgetoastet schön warm schön knusprig
und das passt perfekt darauf deshalb
einfach mal ungefähr die Hälfte in so
ein setzring rein dann können wir da
perfekt ein wunderschön rundes Burger PY
rausformen so das PY ist schön geformt
und jetzt heben wir das hier einmal raus
wunderbar das sieht doch schon Premium
aus oder machen das jetzt mal F ge Style
und Braten unsere Burger pties in
Erdnussöl an wieso kriegst du nur
Mindestlohn ein ordentlich dran Salzen
müssen wir nicht dran geizen an Salz
kümmern wir uns noch schnell um die Soße
das ja Low Carb sein soll wird der
größte Anteil Mayo sein das einzige was
am KBS in die Soß reinkommt ist ein
bisschen siraca und ein kleiner Touch
räucherpaprika so für diese rauchige
Note du darfst das kurz verrühren also
rein mit unseren pties oder rauf mit
unseren pties besser gesagt auf die
Panscher boah das ist wirklich das
zweite ist ein richtiger Apparat und
schön Cross anbraten ich schneid schon
mal unsere Bands auf hier sieht man wie
diese B strukturiert sind auf jeden Fall
interessant aber ich glaube ehrlich
gesagt da wird so viel glänzen von
unseren Burgern dann können wir auch
schon
wenden und das ist wirklich eine
wunderschöne Kruste die sich entwickelt
hat so ein kleiner Trick aus dem
Burgerladen Käse drauf ein kleiner
Schluck Wasser dazu dann geht schon
direkt ab und durch den Dampf der sich
bildet schmilzt der Käse doppelt so
schnell und wir haben perfekt
geschmolzenen echten
chedder mal zusammen oben und unten
kommt ein bisschen von unserer spiriraca
rauchmo drauf demonstrativ unten so ein
zwei Blätter Salat hier ist unser
perfekt geschmolzener Käse wow dann
würde ich sagen nehmen wir auch unsere
petties und platzieren
Sie auf dem Salat so dann fehlen uns
noch unsere schön karamellisierten
Zwiebeln der krönende Abschluss ein paar
Scheiben Bacon und jetzt Deckel drauf
fertig sind unsere Low Carb Burger oh
die sehen echt pervers aus Cars haben
sie wenige low calory hier ist noch mal
der Burger Marvin du warst ja quasi
gerade schon dabei als er zubereitet
wurde ich bin selbst um ehrlich zu sein
ziemlich gespannt was uns jetzt erwartet
probieren wir einfach mal das wird auf
jeden Fall eine Schweinerei Z steht
bereit
super die Teller sind leer und sie
stehen im Saft der Burger petties
fantastisch also wenn das wirklich
gesund wäre dann würde ich se taressen
ich bin vielleicht ein unkultivierter
Typ dementsprechend kann ich wüsste ich
auch hier nicht was man jetzt besser
machen könnte also ich würde auch hier
ze von ze geben das ist krass ne ist ja
so also es ist ja was willst du sonst
besser machen danke schön fand es auch
super lecker also ja dann kann ich mich
nur bedanken und hoffen dass wir da beim
Abendessen wieder anknüpfen können da
gibt's nämlich was interessantes und
zwar mache ich Falaffel Wraps die
Friteuse ist heiß ich mache die
verlaffel komplett selbst deshalb
sollten wir keine Zeit verlieren und
direkt anfangen ich habe hier so ein
food processor also so ein Mixer wo die
Klinge unten sitzt die gebe ich erstmal
meine Kichererbsen rein das sind keine
aus dem Glas sondern die habe ich quasi
getrock
über Nacht aufsaugen lassen Geheimzutat
ein bisschen Backpulver Kreuzkümmel und
Koriander und jede Menge Zwiebel so wie
knoblauuch die schne ich ein bisschen
klein fang an das ganze mal zu mixen
kommen gleich noch ein paar Kräuter
dazu geen wir auch eine Prise Salz dran
und ein wenig Wasser vom einleen der
Kichererbsen damit es sich ein bisschen
besser mixt weiter
geht's und ja das sieht doch gut aus
jetzt gebe ich ein bisschen Koriander
und Petersilie dazu ab
gehtsere schon mal ganz gut aus bisschen
grüner wollen wir sie noch bekommen
haben wir noch ein paar Kräuter draußen
gehackt weil das Ding hat nicht so gut
funktioniert kümmern wir uns als
nächstes um den Salat ich habe einfach
eine Salatschüssel hier sollte man haben
wenn man Salat macht dann Tomaten die
ich einfach in Würfel Schneide kann
ruhig ein bisschen grober sein so Tomate
kommt schon mal in die Salatschüssel
reinentalische Salate sind ja häufig so
kräutersalate also nicht anders machen
wir es im wrap jetzt gebe ich noch ein
bisschen geschnittenene Zwiebel in
Streifen dazu dann wird sich das Ganze
mit ein bisschen Zitrone einmal kräftig
umrühren wer schön frisch lecker und
köstlich noch einmal Salzen weil alles
muss gesalzen sein fertig ist unser
Salat für die frische weiter geht's mit
der wohl wichtigsten Zutat aberbe das
nennt man TUM also eine
knoblauchmajonnaise dafür brauchen wir
insgesamt fünf Zutaten einmal Pflanzenöl
dann eine Knoblauchzehe etwas pigonen
ein Ei einfach komplett reingeben und
ein Spritzer Zitronensaft wichtig immer
dass alles die gleiche Temperatur hat
noch ein wenig Salz dazu dann können wir
auch schon anfangen zu mixen langsam
hochziehen so jetzt haben wir eine sehr
schöne Konsistenz erreicht ich habe hier
meine falaffelmasse und jetzt muss ich
irgendwie mit zwei Löffeln schaffen
schöne verlaffel darus zu formen
irgendwie habe ich das Gefühl dass ich
damit auf keinem schlechten Weg bin
sollach mal machen ja komm risk fun ab
ins Ölbad haben jetzt auf jeden Fall
genug Teig um einige verlaffel zu machen
ich bin gespannt was wir da gleich
rausholen wenn wir dieses Sieb anheben
leute das ist doch wunderschön wir sind
auf dem genau richtigen Weg schön
knusprig und man sieht auf jeden Fall
die sind selbstgemacht aber ey was
soll's richtig schöne Form ich glaube
ein Z Minuten noch und dann ist es
wirklich perfekt ich werde jetzt schon
mal mir mein arabisches pladenbrot
schnappen und dann wird's überlappend
hingelegt damit man nicht so viel Teig
auf einmal im Mund hat jetzt starten wir
mit einer Basis von unserer Knoblauch
Mario aka zum einfach schön verstreichen
damit wir überall was davon haben dann
folgt von unserem Salat richtig Bock
darauf granatapfelsoße und hier sind
unsere Falaffel frei gefüllt hat man bei
jedem Bissen ordentlich Falaffel Zitrone
oben drüber ein paar von diesen
arabischen Salzgurken alles in allem
haben wir so das Grundkonstrukt für
einen sehr leckeren Falaffel wrap und
dann wie bei Burrito von vorne
unterrollen jetzt bewege ich das ganze
auf einen Kontaktgrill um noch mal diese
klassische Röstung dran zu bekommen und
jetzt mache ich mir mein schaut euch das
einfach mal an wunderschön
zacktig ist unser
fast den eine Sache darf nicht fehlen so
diese extra Nocke t oben für den ersten
Bissen mach den zweiten fertig und dann
wird endlich gegessen alles klar mein
lieber hast du ein verlaffel wrap XXL
bestellt mit allem was das Herz begehrt
da werden aber 100 leuteavon oder wir
zwei stoßen wir an stoßen wir an schön
dass du hier warst auch wenn es dir
vielleicht nicht so gut schmeckt wie die
anderen beiden auf jeden Fall ein trauen
bisher mit dir absolut kann ich nur
zurückgeben lass Dir
schmecken das war auf jeden Fall ein
Apparat oder voll ja also nicht ganz
geschafft ähentsprechend satt und jetzt
direkt mal schlafen ich bin gespannt ich
habe das Gefühl das hast was zu sagen ja
und zwar fangen wir direkt mal mit den
verlaffel an ich fand die verlaffel
waren komplett anders als ich sie
erwartet habe es war eine andere
Erfahrung mit verlaffel weil
normalerweise kenne ich das so dass die
so lange frittiert sind dass die
wirklich außen richtig hart sind und
innen dann halt immer noch crunchy und
gar nicht so saftig und ich fand es mal
sehr interessant eine andere Variante zu
zu probieren weil deine waren richtig
saftig von ementsprechend aber von außen
auch nicht so crunchy ja die hät man
wahrscheinlich noch die waren schon
braun aber wahrscheinlich hätte man sie
noch 10 Minuten drin lassen können dann
kriegt man das andere Ergebnis dadurch
dass es halt nicht meine
Lieblingsvariante mit Eisbergsalat ist
und so würde ich einen Punkt Abzug geben
und ich es wäre eine neun von ze von mir
also eine Sache über die ich mich
keineswegs beschweren kann Marvin ich
danke dir dass du heute zu Gast warst
und für diese wahnsinnig guten Bewertung
ich hatte großen Spaß einige Sachen zum
ersten Mal ausprobiert und ihr solltet
unbedingt bei Marvin vorbeischauen denn
dort kommt in der Zukunft wie ich vorhin
meinte etwas auf das ihr euch freuen
könnt ja vielen Dank für die Einladung
es war der eigentlich einer der
schönsten Drehs meines Lebens weil man
sitzt hier man wird bekocht man kann
hier wirklich entspannen bekommt ab und
zu noch mal ein Espresso zwischendurch
also ich komme gerne wieder geil halten
wir fest ihr macht's gut bis dahin ciao
ciao